Broward County Sheriff Scott Israel
faces new calls to resign after claims
that more than one of his deputies
failed to confront the gunman at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school students
and parents returned to the campus
yesterday for the first time since the
shooting Manuel Bojorquez is outside
Stoneman Douglas high in parkland
Florida where classes resumed on
Wednesday and well good morning good
morning sources tell our Miami station
WFOR that his Coral Springs police
officers responded to the shooting they
say they found multiple Broward County
sheriff's deputies waiting outside the
school meanwhile teachers and counselors
met with students here yesterday as they
prepare to head back to class flowers
and letters filled a memorial along the
sidewalk outside campus on Sunday for
many students the emotion is still raw
it hurts I broke its heart
17 people dressed as angels one for each
person killed gathered nearby walking
into the school I feel empowered to see
all this love as students prepare to
return to class the Broward County
Sheriff's Office is facing mounting
pressure over its response to the
shooting including at least one deputy
who resigned after failing to enter the
building during the rampage Broward
County Sheriff Scott Israel on Sunday
said he has displayed amazing leadership
deputies make mistakes police officers
make mistakes we all make mistakes
Israel says his office is looking into
claims at at least three other deputies
failed to confront the alleged gunman
during the shooting the department is
also accused of mishandling some of the
18 phone tips involving the suspected
shooter 16 of them we believe were
handled exactly the way they should two
of them we're not sure if our deputies
did everything they could ever should
have more than 70 Republican state
lawmakers on Sunday demanded Florida
Governor Rick Scott suspend Israel the
same day Scott announced a state run
investigation into the law enforcement
response to the shooting who was called
what was their process how was it broken
give us the facts
according to an internal investigation
sheriff Israel insists that only one of
his deputies was present on campus while
the gunman was there his office says it
will cooperate with the state's
investigation and sheriff Israel says he
will not resign John then well thanks